ptoo versus Charlie this is gonna be a
flash movie video all about the villains
and the cool stuff that I think they're
gonna be doing it look very familiar if
you've been watching the TV show so most
of you have probably seen the flash TV
show at least a little bit you've seen
the things that they've done in the last
two seasons well it seems like the movie
you know even though there's gonna be a
lot of overlap because it's Barry Allen
and the movies Barry Allen on the TV
show the movies are gonna start off with
the Rogues and then work up to the
reverse-flash with like the first big
bad being Captain Cold as you I mean if
you're gonna start off with the rows you
might as well start off with the
fan-favorite
rogue now there are a lot of classic
rogues like heat wave kind of goes hand
in hand with Captain Cold they're doing
him on the TV show so it remains to be
seen which other rogues they put in the
movie but I would expect just at least
three or four rogues we're just like
Captain Cold being the main road
obviously they'll address his origin
story a little bit probably some
flashbacks but I don't think they're
gonna get too bogged down with that in
an even broader context I'm thinking of
it as like a STAR Labs movie because
cyborg won't have his solo movie for a
while I think they're still intending on
doing it but it seems like based on some
of the rumors about Justice League like
they're slowly tuning cyborg down just a
little bit and then they'll weave him in
in a slightly different way later on
like he'll be a much bigger thing in the
second Justice League movie they've
already got so many things to accomplish
in the first Justice League movie gotta
bring Superman back gotta introduce the
idea of the new gods apocalypse so I
think they're just trying to simplify
things and not try to introduce too many
characters all at once so it sounds like
he's kind of getting the Joker treatment
and Suicide Squad like they shot a whole
bunch of Joker for Suicide Squad but it
totally ended up getting cut out Jared
Leto is actually pretty upset about that
but now it sounds like they're just
trying to simplify Justice League a
little bit which I think I'll be very
beneficial but you know there's a lot of
cyborgs in there because he in the flash
are both associated with STAR Labs so
I'm expecting to see his father some of
the shades of those Easter eggs that we
saw in Batman V Superman like we saw the
mother box fuse with him turned him into
the cyborg so that just means there's a
lot of different directions they could
take future flash sequels you could do
the reverse-flash story where he reveals
himself as the architect of Barry's pain
I'm the person that killed your mother I
would expect that even though they're
not doing the exact same story
the TV shows are doing that they'll
still be relatively true to the comic
book origin story for whatever they
change about the plot of the actual
movie like we know whatever the flash is
doing when the movie is going on they're
not gonna like completely reboot his
origin story he'll still be surrounded
by all those chemicals in his workshop
gets struck by lightning booms
speedforce
now obviously the TV show has had a lot
more time to spell that out so you know
about the reverse flash you know about
the other evil speedsters you know about
Wally West you know about the other
people they'll probably get to all that
stuff in the movies too but remember
you've already got so many Justice
League characters that you have to deal
with right now so first things first
just like Avengers had to work up to
Black Panther and Captain Marvel and
spider-man for that matter the same
things gonna happen with the Justice
League characters like the flash the
flash family will grow it's just gonna
take a couple movies to get there but if
any of the DC movies have a chance to be
really really awesome
I think the flash and Batman are really
easy slam dunks Batman for obvious
reasons but the flash when you consider
that we're entering the Geoff Johns era
of DC films he wrote the flash for a
long time a lot of the best flash rogues
stories were his like he knows the
Rogues like nobody else so with his
helpful hand in a solid screenplay
they'll make a totally awesome totally
fun flash movie I'll be interested to
see how they weave in the other Justice
League characters because there's so
much crossover like the big thing now is
Batman showing up in other people's
movies which I'm totally fine with but I
feel like at a certain point Superman
will have to start doing that too maybe
during the Shazam movie just because
Billy Batson looks up to him so much and
I know there been a lot of rumors about
the DC extended universe their film
schedule what they're gonna be doing
later on even like the plot of Justice
League I'll probably address those next
week but the flash is just a really easy
slam-dunk we all know who he is we've
been watching the TV show the movie
version is obviously going to be a
little bit different but mostly just in
the way that it looks the character
dynamics like the characters themselves
will feel very similar to the characters
that you're watching on the TV show like
everybody has like they're slightly
different but like grant gustin's Barry
Allen is just a little bit different
from Ezra Miller's Barry Allen but at
their core they're both trying to do
comic book Barry Allen so they're both
flowing from the same energy and in the
context of the film's - I
feel like the flash is gonna be like
their spider-man the character who is
just like so happy to be there and so
excited that they're doing fun stuff I
need friends I'm keeping this what are
you doing in my second favorite chair
like one of the funniest things about
this - I didn't notice it right away but
a couple times after I watched this
trailer I noticed that in this screen in
the background
he has Rick and Morty on the flash of
the movies watches Rick and Morty how
awesome is that so this is a lot of
awesome stuff in there I would expect
them to dial the flash way up in terms
of screen time during Justice League as
they're tuning things just to make it a
little bit more fun he kind of keeps the
pace up he even makes the Bruce Wayne
character more fun like Bruce Wayne does
have a sense of humor but it depends on
which character he's interacting with
like he's really funny with Aquaman here
because Aquaman's like the super
hardcore intense guy so he slips in that
joke about talking to fish then when
he's interacting with Barry Allen
Barry's like the jokey light hearted guy
so he loosens up just a little bit so
you see like the range of Batman Batman
is made better by the characters around
him
so I am so excited about Aquaman in the
flash in this movie universe now I think
the Aquaman movie is gonna be a little
more intense than some of the others
like it'll be underwater classic James
Wan horror so in the way that the Marvel
films are starting to broaden their
genres like Doctor Strange is gonna be
Marvel's first push into the horror
genre that's gonna be the same thing
with DC's Aquaman film so let me know in
the comments if the flash movie is gonna
start off with the Rogues is like the
big enemies do you think that they're
gonna try and do king shark in gorilla
grodd because the Suicide Squad didn't
want to do king shark because they were
doing all practical effects like they
didn't want an all CG character and you
kind of have to do that for king shark
and I feel like the flash movie could
totally go there the king shark of the
TV show actually looked really really
good gorilla grodd on the TV show looks
really good now imagine you have like an
extra fifty million dollars for special
effects think about how much more badass
they could make those characters but I
don't think they're gonna try and do too
much stuff up front just because they
could totally do gorilla City in the
flash movies I mean they'll have the
money for it that's not the problem they
just have to create that context like
nowhere in the DC Universe so far at the
DC movie universe have they referenced a
city of talk
gorillas like they were blown away when
an alien came to earth so it sounds like
the world still on the edge of learning
about all the crazier stuff that's going
on like the Amazons have been around for
a long time we'll learn about that
during the Wonder Woman movie so clearly
there are metahumans living on the earth
so I think it's the job of the next
couple of movies to let you know just
how comic book II the world is already
like Lex's files during Batman V
Superman kind of give you a teaser for
that like look there's all these
metahumans there's a giant list Aquaman
Wonder Woman the flash just a small
sliver of the amount of people that Lex
has probably been investigating so then
when we got to Suicide Squad Amanda
Waller's like look there are people like
this all over the world all kinds of
terrible organizations are trying to
amass their own teams of metahumans so
that's why we need our Suicide Squad
that was part of her reasoning we need
to put them on our team before somebody
else gets them on their team the other
governments of the earth so definitely
expect future films to address that like
the next Suicide Squad film even a
Justice League film like if they don't
want to go to Darkseid right away they
could totally do like a Justice League
versus in just a society movie like an
evil team-up there's so many evil teams
in the comics you could take your pick
of the litter the flash rogues are just
like the best example but they're
obviously gonna start out in the flash
movie let me know in the comments though
if they did the second Justice League
movie is like Justice League versus and
evil team-up which team would you want
it to be and do you want Lex Luthor to
be on it or do you still kind of want
him working behind the scenes because
he's still like a public figure and once
he goes like super villain like I'm
gonna kill you Superman in the world
sees it they kind of turn on him so it
just depends on how quickly the movies
want to throw Lex Luthor under the bus
but I think it's gonna be a while before
we see Lex Luthor and his comic-book
armor but just as a teaser this isn't
flash related this is Superman related
but Henry Cavill has been studying
jiu-jitsu for a long time like the last
couple of years hardcore so just think
about jiu-jitsu Superman versus
Steppenwolf in this first Justice League
film Superman comes back and is just a
badass just wails on Steppenwolf I
cannot wait to see black costume mullet
Superman beat the out of him it's
gonna be so much fun but just a reminder
a DC giveaway going on right now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video there'll
be more flash TV show stuff happening
soon there's a big convention this
weekend Dragon Con is happening and
there's a bunch of flash cast there
they've already started talking about
flash season 3 stuff so I'll do video
for Dragon Con flash stuff in the next
couple of days but they actually just
revealed the new costumes for thor
odin's a bunch of people and thor
ragnarok like loki so i'll be doing a
video for that tomorrow they also may
have revealed the release date of Game
of Thrones wins a winter the new book so
I'll probably be doing a video for that
tomorrow too
will you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to learn more about
what's going on with the flash season 3
and you can click here to learn how
spider-man and Doctor Strange are gonna
figure it in to the Avengers timeline
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight